[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday October 7th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
this week the Nobel Prize in physics was
awarded to three scientists Elia spare
John clauser and Anton zeilinger for
their work on quantum physics and
particularly for helping lay the
foundations for Quantum computing
unlike the bits that power traditional
computers quantum computers use quantum
bits or qubits to run algorithms that
makes them faster and more efficient and
that's something businesses and
governments really want
joining us to explain the Nobel Winner's
discoveries and where they're taking the
world of computing is our science
reporter Eric nealer hi Eric thanks for
joining us good morning how you doing
today I'm doing great although maybe a
little bit confused with this topic in
this simplest of terms can you kind of
describe to us why these scientists won
sure these scientists did some
experiments decades ago that really
opened the door to something called
Quantum Computing Quantum Computing
promises to solve all sorts of complex
problems that existing supercomputers
really can't handle that could include
the folding of proteins in molecules
that can be used to discover new drugs
that could be understanding how the
earth's climate is changing and all the
variables and temperature and weather
and so forth that influence that it
could also mean maximizing shipping
routes for hundreds of tankers across
the world
describe to me this concept of
entanglement because it seems to be
pretty critical to what we're
understanding here so this is when two
or more of these subatomic particles
sort of share a destiny so whatever
influences one happens to the other and
vice versa you know Albert Einstein
referred to this phenomena famously as
something called spooky action at a
distance because the entanglement ties
the states of these particles together
even when they're separated by great
distances so what these scientists did
was really understand something in the
fundamental concepts of entanglement and
how it works and what these mysterious
interactions what influences them and
what makes them happen
why does that matter for making
computers work faster so understanding
entanglement has helped scientists today
better able to sort of manipulate
control and work with the subatomic
particles to transmit information to run
algorithms for example much more
efficiently than supercomputers that are
using this strings of ones and zeros and
bits there's also this opportunity for
Quantum encryption and also for using
the concept of entanglement to help with
secure Communications how would that
work
one of the things with qubits is that
from a cyber security perspective if a
hacker tries to observe them in transit
in their super fragile Quantum state
it collapses and so the hacker can't
really tamper with these qubits without
leaving behind a Telltale sign of their
activity
so some companies have already taken
advantage of this property to create new
networks for transmitting sensitive data
based on something called Quantum key
distribution
so this is still an emerging field but
the promise of quantum communication
secure transmission of data is really
been opened the door by these
experiments that were done decades ago
by these three scientists how far along
is the development of quantum Computing
I mean when might we expect this to be
just part of our world
right IBM does have a quantum computer
they are running some applications on it
one of the things is in addition to just
technical issues of computation and so
forth it requires a lot of energy to
keep that processor so cold I spoke with
someone at IBM and they are working with
clients such as Boeing and Exxon to help
them with their data needs to look at
large patterns of data that can help
them so there are some applications
being run it's not ready for prime time
what Jerry Chao an IBM fellow and
director of quantum infrastructure at
IBM told me said that we're not at the
point where Quantum Computing provides a
real business advantage
but they're trying to unlock value over
time so it's it's it's still on the
horizon but there's a lot of promise and
there's actually quite a bit of money
going into Quantum Computing right now
all right that was our science reporter
Eric nealer thanks for joining us Eric
you're welcome great to be with you
and that's it for Tech news brief
our producer Julie Chang our supervising
producer is Chris sinsley and I'm your
host Zoe Thomas thanks for listening and
have a great weekend
foreign
[Music]
[Music]